In the last video, we tried
to draw a 2-Propylheptane.
And we did our best attempt at
drawing it, but it was pointed
out that this wouldn't even be
called a 2-Propylheptane to
begin with.
So you actually should never
see something called
2-Propylheptane.
Let me show you what
I'm talking about.
So when do you see something
like this, you might
immediately say-- and the way
we drew it was actually
correct, it just wouldn't be
called 2-Propylheptane.
So you say heptane.
So that is a seven
carbon alkane.
No double bond, so one, two,
three, four, five, six, seven.
And then on the second carbon,
so you have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven, we
have a propyl group.
Propyl, that is three carbons.
So on the second carbon we
have a propyl group.
That's three carbons.
So that is one, two, three.
And so the way we drew it
was just like this.
And so if someone gave you
2-Propylheptane, this would be
what you would draw.
But you wouldn't call this
2-Propylheptane.
Because remember, if you're
given the molecule you look
for the longest chain and the
longest chain here is not the
heptane chain.
It is not one, two, three, it is
not this thing in magenta--
in this kind of mauve color.
It's this chain where
you start over here.
If you start over here, one,
two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, you actually
get a longer chain.
So this would actually be the
backbone of this molecule
right over there.
That right over there would be
the backbone, and so you
would number it.
You start numbering closest to
the group that's attached, so
one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine.
So you have nine carbons in
your backbone, so we're
dealing with nonane.
We're dealing with nonane.
And you have a methyl group:
one carbon attached to the
fourth carbon of our
main backbone.
So this is going to be four
methyl, this is our methyl
group right here,
4-Methylnonane.
So it was brought up, I think
the user name is Minoctu, and
they correctly corrected me,
that there would never be such
a thing as 2-Propylheptane.
I just made that up.
If someone were to, kind of,
label this molecule they would
call it 4-Methylnonane
and ask you draw it.
But either way, both of
these would point you
in the right direction.
This would just be the incorrect
name for it, because
you'd be looking at-- if someone
gave you this molecule
and you named it this way,
that would be incorrect.
So I apologize for this.
This is 4-Methylnonane.
If you do heptane you're not
finding the longest chain.